what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
birds a trailer official teaser trailer
the birds of trailer that I say that you
did say no we're gonna watch the birds
up from a little under the weather birds
the free official teaser trailer I'm
excited for this man I to get in the
spirit of things about to give DC
Universe a plug here to get in the
spirit of things I've been reading some
Harley Quinn comics according to my
history I have read the Batman
adventures Mad Love Suicide Squad number
7
I read Batman Harley Quinn it's the one
that has the cover photo that it was
famously recreated in Suicide Squad best
moment of any who's is pretty short but
let's check it out
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
steampunk
[Music]
now that is a teaser that's a train well
that's a teaser trailer if I didn't know
what quick flashes at the very most yeah
I mean it didn't really do much else
different for me then that b-roll
footage they showed before I mean the
thing that got me most excited was when
you see kind of that funhouse maze of
look like Harley Quinn was jacking up
some people there and you got a bit of a
tone of having some of that like
steampunk 5 I think if you have like the
steampunk I come by with that b-roll
footage they look like a little bit of
an appearance film away you know this
reminds me of the b-roll footage if the
b-roll footage took place on the set of
the film yeah this looks like a DC
Universe show okay you kind of saw
huntress in action yet kindness Black
Canary in action you're verifying what
we are yeah which is we're gonna have
some badass ladies they're gonna have
some asses and you know I mean I got
especially excited when white male Ewan
McGregor showed up on the screen yeah
cuz you know he's playing black mask
which is a classic Batman villain I feel
like by the end of the film the finale
he's gonna dawn the black mask heard
they were in reshoots I heard that yeah
there's something like controversy
surrounding like the Rouge reshooting
the whole ending because they apparently
they weren't satisfied with it you never
know which one of these reports to
believe anymore but go read Grace
Randolph's because hers is is
interesting oh is it she's putting out
details today she was like they're
changing the ending because of a
specific plot detail about picks and
then they're really retooling the movie
like Star Wars rogue one style and
chads2 hell ski is coming in to like do
some story adjustments as well as action
that's what grace Randolph said she even
tweeted a picture of like a conversation
with her private contact Wow
so I don't know what's happening to this
movie but it's been an eventful day I
mean they have to promote her it's
coming out in a few months yeah yeah and
I'm curious about again those reports
about Chad Starsky coming in and doing
stuff to the movie especially because
this is a big make the action better
damn it
damn its chance to house gain your great
action why are you coming in to make
things better well in C even he now is
like just knowing this is a very thin
link but knowing the behind the scenes
and everything it's like that Deadpool
vibe is just rubbing off all over those
John wick guys because you know this is
a very meta
you know silly and I know that has to do
with the studio but you know it's coming
kind of close to the territory and
especially I gotta imagine the tone of
this movie is gonna be garish and glia
off the wall I heard they wanted this
trailer to only be exclusively at you
know it playing during like in chapter 2
or in theaters
yeah then when you see the opening of
this and like that's why I heard that
this is supposed to be a surprise I mean
the surprise is automatically ruined
it's like even if you have the balloons
they're not fully committed to the bit
because the balloons are flying over the
DC logo well you know you're not
watching some penny wise things well but
you see that would be your first clue
like if this was the theaters I feel
like they would run this after the whole
life welcome to whatever movie theater
you chose and then it's like all the
movies starting on no it's not starting
cuz DC's here last for 1.5 seconds yeah
yeah yeah once the joke appeals it's
like yeah you don't get the Harley Quinn
hitting the balloon thing as powerfully
because of the fact that this up as
birds-of-prey
teaser trailer on the internet so you
already know oh yeah but even I'm saying
even the theaters hasn't worried the
illusion would last not Barrett yeah but
yeah I'm excited for to see Margot
Robbie returning the role I'm excited to
see what I mean he looks like he's
having a total blast that's a much more
loose interpretation of Black Mass I'm
used to just seeing Black Mass when it's
like it was really serious black mass
was seeing a fun version of him in Ewan
McGregor I read some birds of prey
comics Harley Quinn's not in any of
those comics because so but he's the
lead of this let's see what happens you
know because she is so popular I'm sure
new rock stars will be able to give us
see thoroughly in-depth breakdown of
every single frame of this guy's heart
one will be 40 minutes all right guys
what do you think of this birds-of-prey
trailer leave a comment down below
before we wrap this video up I want to
thank everyone who has download and
follow us on the Stardust app over there
with you 30 second reaction movie
turn to film TV show and or trailer we
post throughout the week plenty of other
YouTube personalities are on there as
well you can post your own reactions as
well whole thing's freak do it today you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell and hope
you have a good time leave your comments
about birds of prey down below and also
leave some recommendations of which
birds of prey comics to read or Harley
Quinn comics does this app is awesome